this report broke from the New York
Times essentially saying that the
president was told that Putin did
personally call for the hacking into our
elections Karl Rove is back with us he's
joined by Richard Goodstein a democratic
strategist and policy expert Saul
Weissenberg the former deputy
independent counsel during whitewater
Karl I had to rudely interrupt you
before we broke for commercial what's
your reaction to this New York Times
report it frankly doesn't really
surprise me because Brennan was pretty
much on to this Russia behind the
meddling six months earlier it's from
from what I could tell so it doesn't
really surprise me that the president
would be briefed on us yeah look no it
doesn't surprise me either and frankly
remember early in the administration I
think the President had a line that I
wish he had used on Monday which is he
said early in his term that of course he
would like to know if anybody meddled in
an American election and because he
would want to make certain that it was
stopped and I wish the President had
that tone on Monday but no this this
latest report doesn't surprise me what
what did surprise me was the ability of
the Muller investigation in our
governments cyber forensics to be able
to identify the specific actors 12 actor
sitting he imagined those guys sitting
in their office and the GRU and and
going online and seeing their names and
figure and asking the question of how
could they tell it was us yeah and it's
all I want to ask you specifically about
that that indictment that dropped last
Friday one indictment twelve Russian GRU
and other officers what of that what I
mean I thought why name them why not
keep that under seal and actually try to
see if maybe one of them comes to the
United States parently some of them
maybe have been to the United States I
mean what's the theory behind that well
I don't know what the theory is but if
you don't put them under seal you know
you're never going to get them over here
they're there GRU officers and I think
the point of the indictment these people
will never appear in the US Court the
point of the indictment was to by Muller
sometime and to say look I'm really
doing things that I'm doing important
things but it's really a speaking
indictment and I don't doubt that he'll
be able to he'll prove that it's just
that he'll never be called on to prove
it but indictment for our view
just to be clear again an indictment are
the charges you do not yet see all the
evidence obviously they wouldn't put it
all a lot of it's very sensitive but
there the charges against these
individually they don't forget that
people think when you're like a lot of
people are indicted and they're not
they're not guilty many liberals used to
believe that but not saying they're not
guilty but people have to remember if
we're gonna blame Trump for not having
smart verbiage we have to be smart with
our verbiage to Laura in every criminal
case every criminal case state or
federal the judge tells the jury the
indictment is not proof the indictment
is not evidence and yet I saw and the
other networks constantly here we have
the proof here we have the evidence now
look if Muller didn't think he had it
he's perpetrated a massive fraud and I
don't think he has but but you know and
Andy McCarthy made the comment that
basically now all the Russians are
presumed innocent because this has been
put into an indictment but the real
point is is this is a this is a speaking
indictment meant to buy time for Bob
Muller
so no Americans named in it no American
actions reference but nevertheless it
you know would ate up some of the news
cycle and the president apparently
Richard approved the timing said it was
okay to pan down the indictment I guess
they they've checked with the White
House or and he basically said it was
okay which kind of kills the narrative
that Trump was like worried about the
indictments but your reaction Richard
can I react to this New York Times story
what's newsworthy about it is one of two
things either Trump has no faith
whatsoever in the intelligence community
because if he does just today there's an
another New York Times story saying well
I hold Putin responsible in the sense
that he's the head of the country just
like people hold me responsible for what
goes on here know if you were told two
weeks before the indictment that Putin
personally and directly was overseeing
this subversion of the US democracy
that's not oh well he's runs the country
no that's very specific and Trump still
can't acknowledge that that's
troublesome well that's what that's what
he said tonight when CBS News that's
what Donald Trump said tonight that
Putin is responsible I would he's in
charge of the country like I consider
that's different know that to say he's
cause he's in charge
it's like saying oh we are the managers
responsibility this is where Karl Rove I
think with your experience in the Bush
administration they're playing I hate
the multi level chest reference but he
does have other concerns other than just
what's happening in the Muller
investigation what the New York Times is
going to publish he just had this
meeting with Putin now I imagine and he
references today Karl they were talking
about Israel Iran Syria nuclear
nonproliferation getting back to some
semblance of a whatever a normal
relationship with Russia is that does
come into play an Obama reference this
Karl back in 2016 he's like
insulting someone on the world state
that doesn't accomplish anything and I
don't recall george w bush insulting
Putin whether in Crawford at the ranch
or the Clintons when they were meeting
and when Hillary was meeting with Lavrov
you don't insult people even if you know
they're trying to mess around with our
systems which they always have been
trying to mess around with our systems
yeah well look III agree with you I
don't take umbrage president Trump
should not have been there for the
purpose of slamming President Putin to
his face
nor am I worried about having a solitary
meeting President Bush for example Metsa
met on a one-on-one literally drove the
king of Saudi Arabia around his ranch in
Crawford and discussed very important
issues and I think that's over an
overreach I do think the president
needed to project strength on Monday and
he didn't by his words it was when he
was asked that question he could have
answered in a way that would have Putin
would have known that he was then he was
upset about it and know and knew that
the Russians were behind it but it could
have been straight forward and strong
without being insulting and the
president didn't hit that note on Monday
to get a better job on CBS tonight even
that tone would have been fine on Monday
but there's no need for the President to
go in and insult world leaders just for
the sake of insulting world leaders
particularly if you're trying to find a
way forward there are important things
that we need to do we've got serious
questions about the Russians and living
up to their existing treaty agreements
on the intermediate-range missile treaty
we have
we have a treaty with them negotiated by
President Bush that comes up for renewal
in 2021 on nuclear weapons we have
concerns about them in that regard we we
I hope the president brought up their
there they're not helping us in North
Korea Lavrov as you remember shows up
one week before the meeting at Singapore
he shows up in Penang to basically tell
the North Koreans we got your back if
the Americans know it's in Russian leave
them there that's gonna be okay but I
think the president should give an
address to the nation about this and and
saw Richard Karl where he talks about
our relationship with Russia
basically what they discussed at this
meeting and what could be improved
without no Muller reference no Peter
struck reference none of that but given
address to the nation fantastic panel
guys thank you so much I know it was
short tonight with all this breaking
news